[Music]
let's bring in tom e kern he gets to
cover the patriots an insider for nbc
sports boston when did you start
covering the patriots
1997 pete carroll's first year oh what
do you remember about pete
he was relentlessly optimistic and
upbeat and just really
not ready for the cynical mean
spirited nature of the post parcells
patriots media what was your initial
reaction when belichick got hired
that
it's obvious that they should have done
it three years before and i asked robert
kraft and his introductory press
conference why didn't you hire him after
parcells left
and he said you know he was too close to
parcells it's a good question but he was
too close to parcells at the time
you start to look at this this game it
feels almost like a build up to a super
bowl with with the media coverage um
what is it like locally and and it does
it have that feel
yeah it absolutely does i think there's
fatigue and there's less conversation
about what's going to happen between the
lines as opposed to what the reactions
will be what are the reactions of the
fans
what do the patriots do as an
organization when brady breaks brees's
record with 68 more yards to become the
career passing leader um who plays like
ass
brady or mac
those are the things that are are more
focused on than hey how are they going
to hold back that tampa bay front
you know there's so many questions on
the outside that people i think are
asking like does it mean more to
belichick does it mean more to brady
could you quantify an answer with that
i think the individual victory it has
it's going to have a lot to do with the
nature of the win and the nature of the
game you know the patriots are one and
two but they haven't played really well
in any of the three games
this is post brady so they're seven and
whatever eight and eleven since he left
but they spent all the money so people
like myself expected hey it's gonna be
probably a 12-win season just by osmosis
and if it's not and they get their asses
handed to them dan
it's gonna be
very
disgruntled by the second half inside
that stadium and you know that nbc will
cut from the noise of the fans to bill
to the fans to bill to brady on the
other side the optics won't be great
what answer did you want out of
belichick when you interrupted you know
let let me play it again
no it was into
were you rude
it popped out of my mouth before i knew
it was popping out all right here is uh
tom curran going toe-to-toe with bill
belichick he spoke on wbei today
about tom brady looking at his options
and he decided tampa was a better option
why weren't the patriots a better option
for him when both robert kraft
and brady himself said over and over
how much they wanted him to finish his
career here
yeah well i mean i'm not going to go
back and rehash all that we've talked
about that really we've never talked
about it
with us the focus is on the game here
and
look i have so much respect and
appreciation for tom and everybody okay
so tom what did you what did you expect
belichick to say
see here's the thing is
it popped out of my mouth because it's
several years and i've had a good
relationship with bill i don't think
it's awesome right now but
several years of him saying that we've
talked about things that were never
talked about so that
fell out
what i would love for him to say is see
he's being disingenuous the offer and
the option that brady looked at
relative to the patriots was never what
he asked for and was never what they
kind of agreed to give him in the summer
of 2019 in the summer of 2019 it was a
very simple request from brady the
breeze contract two years 50 million
dollars all guaranteed we're done i'll
stay here through 2020.
patriots instead gave him a kind of
phony second year and an 8 million
dollar bump and that's what he said you
know what so when it got to 2020 there
was no option offered by the patriots so
maybe i was looking for bill to say you
know what tom let's just put it this way
philosophically both on the football
field and financially for our roster
the option that tom had in tampa bay was
going to be superior to the one that we
offered we weren't in a position to
match anything that they were going to
do philosophically or financially
that's better than uh we talked about it
when you didn't
yeah you can't rehash if you haven't
hashed and
men i mean that but you're right
belichick has a way of just saying you
know we you know we we've discussed that
like in in bill's world he discussed it
by maybe having one line
you know reporters want to know there's
more to this uh seth wickersham has a
new book out on the patriots kind of
behind the curtain here
uh do you think anything is unearthed
with the relationship or lack thereof of
brady and belichick
i think there'll be a lot of on our
thing of details behind it i you know in
terms of anecdotal stuff and you know
reading some of the excerpts today it's
it's going to be a fascinating read you
know just the whole triangle of
agitation that was going on
is going to be interesting to read but
brady loved the success of the patriots
he hated the interpersonal relationship
that he had with belichick and he hated
it because it could have been better and
should have been better and he wanted it
to be better
but it just wasn't going to be that way
and he knew that he was going to go the
way of menkins or seymour
or vina terry or law or whoever he knew
that was awaiting him that's why he
wanted to get ahead of it
and that's why he kept asking for the
extensions do you think when bill
wouldn't do it he was just you know i
know what's gonna he's gonna do to me
but tom had to know bill belichick is
not capable of being that kind of coach
touchy feely yes
how come he can do it with like the 38th
guy on the roster but he can't do it
with his best player because he can and
he does
you think that he could be you know a
bruce aryan's kind of guy oh no no
but you you're not looking for bruce
arians but say for instance it's you
know the week before the 2018 super bowl
or afc championship and your hand gets
ripped open to an extent that it does
and there's a real question as to
whether or not you're going to play and
you play through the pain of it and
everything and then someone asked you
about it's not heart surgery it's not
like you have
that's important
so i mean you're like that's gratuitous
that's gratuitous crappiness toward the
kid and at some point he's like well
that's that's just he's got it out for
me specifically because of the level
i've risen to i think in many ways
it's he he
someone had a great line to me it was
one of the people in the organization
about wes welker
belichick
adored wes welker at three million
dollars a year
at nine million dollars a year
i hate it
hate it
so there you have it yeah
i just don't know if you see bill
after they win a super bowl
i mean he he does
there is a motion there
he holds tom like he's his son
but then 10 minutes after
it's done he's over with
like
it's over six times in his life he's
shown that kind of emotion
and that's when they win a super bowl
he's not incapable of the emotion he's
not incapable of of human warmth i mean
he's done many unbelievably generous
philanthropic things and he still does
he's he's not a
horrible person it's just with his
employees in order for him to get from
them what he wants
he has to treat them he believes in a
certain way especially the ones who are
quote unquote above the others
but lawrence taylor
i mean he coached the best offensive
player and the best defensive player
arguably in nfl history but lawrence
taylor got miles and miles and miles of
bill bending over backwards for him and
there's probably a reason for that
because bill still hadn't been a head
coach
and lawrence was his pathway to become a
head coach just to make sure that he was
on the field and you could bend to get
things from him but if lawrence taylor
was playing for belichick as a head
coach
how would bill have treated lawrence
taylor i think it'd be different
i think it would be different until the
outlier skills
you know became a distraction see brady
belichick believed
was imminently replaceable
brady knew that
belichick held that sentiment belichick
was not shy about sharing that sentiment
lawrence taylor wasn't replaceable
and that's the biggest part of of
brady's you know being elsewhere i mean
belichick really would have loved to
have gone with jimmy garoppolo it's
interesting think about it what would
have happened if 28 3
turned into 3114
or 42 to 10.
the timeline would have been perfect
that's 2016. you say goodbye to tom
jimmy's a quarterback you're only or
you're on your way instead they have
that miraculous comeback and brady's the
mvp in 2017 and now you're screwed
his belichick
like driven by ego that that you know he
wants to be viewed as i'm the reason why
we win
not tom brady and that competition that
he did not like
i think that's a pretty big facet of it
yeah
damn and he will obviously say it's you
know it's the players it's the players
it's the players but
a lot of those players because bill is a
general manager are players who are
unearthed by bill you know so whether
it's creating matt slater or
um david andrews you look along their
offensive line and started with
undrafted guys or malcolm butler or dev
mccourty who was a surprise first round
pickachu rob mayo who's
those are guys that bill fines and then
when he says it's the players the
players the players well how did those
players get there well julian edelman
got there because bill was prescient
enough to hire him or wes welker is a
you know
a scrub in miami so it cuts both ways
but bill is absolutely very
concerned with
who he has to share the spotlight
and the acclaim with and he does it
but he doesn't want to to get to the
point where it's an actual conversation
okay is it mcdaniel's or bill
he doesn't want that
what happened sunday night
and i was talking to our friend rich
eisen and i used to did you watch game
of thrones
so i'm trying to kind of film with that
i don't know i don't have time it must
be nice to watch you yeah
i am on the throne i do you know who i
am i'm bill belichick i'm on the throne
yeah your game of enthusiasm
curb your throne
so what happens on sunday night do you
think
buccaneers raffle
what'll be interesting i think is bill
will hatch a game plan to make sure that
he doesn't get
40 dropped on him that means people are
deep all night and you invite leonard
fournette and
ronald jones to run the football as much
as possible
so i'm thinking like 27-13 okay 27-17
okay finish this sentence
what if the patriots win the game
uh you're gonna see just huge
vindication and and elation
and i mean it'll be
it'll be a massive upset
okay and i the interesting thing is in
games like this if you said what if the
patriots win the game when they were
backed into a corner it would be because
of brady i don't know who it would
because be because of
this week i don't know what individual
player would have an out-of-body
experience to deliver that win
post-game handshake hug
neither
depends on the result
buccaneers buccaneers win probably a
pregame hug
pre-game
pre-game hug
yeah
uh paulie wants to take you up on that
bet what's you want to bet with curran
on this i could see a pregame
conversation and maybe a pregame
handshake but a hug
i think if you're going to have a
conversation you're going to have a hug
initiated by whom
tom no
oh [ __ ] bill it would always be the
initiator oh the initiative based off
what wait there's a deflator the
initiator because you don't go running
up to your 1950s dad and embrace him you
wait for him to make the first move son
i was always very proud of you you know
i always told the guys down at the bar i
love you
that's that's the relationship brady's
not gonna run over and hug him like me
and genie did remember remember that
whole thing with me and she didn't run
out and hug him and then bill wouldn't
hug him and then phil ran out and hugged
him harder
paulie has 16. to his name you're
willing to bet 16
no pregame
hug or handshake no pregame hug
handshake is implied handshake is in
play that's too specific for me to put
that then i need odds
i'll give you 30 to your 15. i'll come
up with some scratches 30 dollars you're
15. right i'll give you 15 bucks if
there's no pregame hug just for the
action really okay
because because now there's a reason to
watch the game
well now i have action on pregame
uh do you get to talk to belichick
anymore this week
yeah uh
friday morning it'll be a fun day it's
usually good on fridays
[Laughter]
thank you tom
bye-bye play nice that's tommy curran he
covers the patriots he's an insider
there he interrupted bill belichick